Veta zombie mode you are the hunter and
your goal is simple find and kill all
human survivors although you play alone
against team of players your advantage
lies in your skills we want to show you
some of them and how you can creatively
use them in come first
you can mark the targets and some on the
zombie horde to do the bloody work for
you and if you stick the Horde spit to
the enemy there's no way they can avoid
it you can also use the Horde to create
chaos among human players get them
separated and once they on their own
they're easy to pick
remember that the only defense your
opponents have against you is their UV
flashlights
here's your UV suppressor skill to
disable them for a few seconds and leave
your enemies completely defenseless try
to hit all of them at once if they group
and make a few kills in a row once the
UV lights suppress you can easily insta
kill people with the pounce skill and
remember you can also use it mid-air
it's not only super effective but it
also looks pretty awesome on top of that
you can use ground pound it's perfect
for sending enemies flying and killing
them before they hit the ground and
don't forget about the tackle it's
pretty all-purpose skill use it to
damage your opponent's throw them of
buildings or it's a bit more tricky
tackle them into spikes
it's just a sneak peek into what the
night hunter is capable off join
hundreds of thousands of players and be
the zombie